a mass expression of alarm from cities
on every continent demonstrators from
all walks of life calling for immediate
action not just promises in the crisis
over climate control
all over the world there's outrage that
in the past so many pledges to cut
emissions and provide funding to create
clean alternatives to fossil fuels
haven't been honored
it begs the global question if state
leaders reneged on promises in the past
then how can they be trusted now
disillusionment about cop26 filled these
glasgow streets just a short distance
from the summit venue
here an indigenous guardian of the
amazon rainforest from costa rica are
you angry
yes i'm angry we've been saying this for
years we're at a point of no return but
governments are just not listening
and nearby a mother who works as a
clerical assistant
our generation and previous generations
have created such issues with the world
that my children are going to end up
inheriting so if we don't try and sort
it out now we're just going to leave the
future children with major problems that
they will never be able to overcome
this aid worker was trying to be
optimistic
we have the answers to this climate
crisis we've got the money we need to
support vulnerable communities we just
need our world leaders and the
negotiations the climate summit
happening right now to do it at the
speed we need it but such optimism
though was in short supply generally
cop 26 is now halfway through and the
pressure on world leaders and their
representatives the climate diplomats
couldn't be greater the message from the
streets here and cities across the globe
is quite clear
they must do better demonstrators turned
out in australia where forest fires at
the end of 2019 and the beginning of
2020 killed 33 people and more than a
billion wild animals
in south korea protesters expressed
doubts about whether their government
would honor promises to phase out
coal-fired power
i think it would be difficult for south
korea to stop its acts as a climate
villain
back in glasgow some complex
negotiations will be underway in the
coming days to try to find a solution to
this climate crisis
no one in the meeting rooms will need
reminding of the huge level of pressure
upon them
andrew simmons al-jazeera glasgow